kids say the darndest things but
sometimes they also come up with the
darndest things - from funny kid test
answers to some of the most hilarious
real life situations wait until you see
what these kids got up to stick around
to see the ultimate cosplay that will
leave you laughing for hours don't
forget to subscribe to the things and
give this video a big thumbs up now
let's get to the 20 kids who are so
funny they might be geniuses circle a
tornado let's start with this genius
sometimes tests can be pretty confusing
like this one for example the question
states which location would be the most
dangerous during a tornado but the kid
got confused because the answer is
underneath made it seem like circle one
is also an answer in school at a park
and in a store all sound like they're
the right type of answers but doesn't
circle one also look like an actual
answer we can't blame this kid for
picking it and their explanation is
actually pretty spot-on circling a
tornado would be more dangerous than
most of the other options mentioned
grownups are weird kids sometimes give
us unique perspectives and what they
think adults are like like this child
who actually said something everyone
wants to say but we don't the kid said
that every adult says how are you and
you always have to say you're doing good
even though you're really not doing that
good this kid is totally right adults
don't really want to know how you're
doing unless you your best friends it's
just small talk and weirdly done at that
and it's about time someone called them
out on it well done kid quadrilaterals
we've mentioned this a couple of times
in our other videos but it's one of our
favorite fails ever sure hope totally
missed the point but she's a clear
genius she was asked to name the
quadrilaterals in case you didn't know
there are things like parallelograms
rectangles rhombuses squares trapezoids
and so on and so on but hope had a
different idea
she literally named them and it's
absolutely hilarious our favorite is Ted
assume the rectangle but we also love
Bob the square even Kate with a C and
Harry with one are adorable a total
genius Chinese this one is just simply
amazing this kid had a pretty
interesting homework assignment he had
to become a Chinese immigrant in the
1870s and
a letter home describing his experiences
but instead of running it in English
this kid wrote it in Chinese here are
some of the things they said in their
essay the life here is bad the working
condition is not good and lacks employee
benefits however please do not worry I
am working very hard here and will soon
take care of myself how is everyone
I missed all of you a lot and hope that
you can meet again and now is it this
kid is a genius stuck on an island this
one is also pretty clever this kid got
asked if they would rather be stuck on
an island all alone or with one person
they hate and they also had to explain
why we'd probably rather be stuck on an
island all alone but this kid said
they'd rather be stuck on an island with
someone they hated so they could eat
them that's a pretty intense thought
right but if you think about it it's
actually quite genius even though it's
definitely barbaric seriously some of
these kids are pretty terrible but you
have to admit they are still clever
geniuses note cards you might wonder
what this is about and it might not be
clear unless you see the caption of the
photo a teacher posted a photo with a
caption saying they will always allow
three by five note cards in their exams
to help them out this girl took it to a
new level when she realized the teacher
never specified whether he meant inches
or feet yup you're right she actually
brought a three by five foot note card
to class and what's even better is the
fact that the teacher approved it even
though we have a feeling he probably
specified the clear measurements
afterwards we have what here's another
total genius unscrambling words can be
hard especially if the words can have
more than one meaning like this kid that
had to figure out what these scrambled
words actually mean do you see their
response we have what now that's
definitely not what the actual words
supposed to say it's supposed to be we
have this what's even better is the fact
that the words are clearly written in
the top right corner but still you have
to admit that this is pretty hilarious
we seriously hope this kick out some
bonus points because they definitely
deserve them
spelling spelling is not easy for kids
especially when they're first trying to
learn it but you have to admit that this
kid is a clear genius for figuring out
this little spelling secret they had to
write ten words they can spell seems
like it shouldn't be a complicated task
right but instead of actually writing
ten word
they can spell they just copied the
words from the instruction they also
added the word octopus and the number
seven and two seriously this is pretty
genius and we bet most kids would never
figure that out this kid is an actual
inspiration married forever this is not
a test answer but it's an interesting
inside and what kids know about being
married and you'd be totally surprised
by their answers Ricky might just be ten
years old but he knows that in order to
make your marriage work you need to tell
your wife that she's pretty and then he
makes it even better by adding you need
to tell her she's pretty even if she
looks like a truck the teacher even made
a joke out of it by adding that Ricky's
clearly going to stay married forever
and with his advice you can do the same
two simple right white out okay this one
has to be one of our favorite funny
moments we have ever seen it's just pure
genius and we've never seen anything
like this we never dared to do this as
kids but we also didn't think about
doing it either Jackie had a brilliant
idea of whiting out the questions she
didn't know the answer to instead of
actually answering it how amazing is
that it's pretty clever she even thought
of it in the first place even though
it's very clear that the teacher wasn't
so impressed with Jackie's wit but don't
worry Jackie because we are definitely
impressed heartless creatures this one
is also pretty funny this kid had to
answer a question about evolution they
were shown three pictures of giraffes
two of them were eating the tree but you
can also see the third one being too
short to reach the tree by the third
picture the giraffes life was lost
instead of answering the question the
kids simply wrote that giraffes are
heartless creatures which is true if you
consider that the two giraffes didn't
even offer food to the other one and in
case you're wondering which answer is
actually correct this is known as
Lamarck's theory of evolution bacon we
have no idea what this kid's name is
supposed to be at the top right corner
but that's not the point of this picture
this child had to fill out the blanks
make a story out of it but instead of
choosing any other words that would
probably be less cruel the kid gave
everyone a reality shock a pig really is
a pig until it becomes bacon just in
case you didn't know that already he
gets a bonus point for creativity but
loses a bonus point because he didn't
spell bacon right either way this is
pretty hilarious and so true wild
answers we've talked a lot about
spelling test today but here's another
one this kid really had the wildest
answers ever but we're
totally here for them the kid seems to
have a thing for kittens because they
use the word in almost every single
sentence they have to make but what
makes this even better is the teachers
comments or the fact that the kids still
manage to get a hundred percent on this
spelling test even though they gave some
of the most wild answers we've ever seen
to be fair all of these answers could
have been turned into viral tweets 100
years this one is also one of our
favorite answers ever we've seen a
couple of these floating around but this
kid takes it to a new level
gram was asked what he'll be doing when
he's 100 years old he drew an awesome
image of him breaking out of his tomb
talk about having ambition to be fair
Graham could actually be a hundred years
old and not be in his tomb also but we
like this version much better come to
think of it we also couldn't wait to
break out of our tombs and cause havoc
when we reach 100 years of age sounds
like fun judging by Graham's image
highest frequency you've probably seen
this one before too but it's just so
good we have to feature it again
Mariah Carey lovers this one's for you
when asked what is the highest frequency
noise a human can reach a kid replied
that it's Mariah Carey well that's
technically true normal human frequency
is around 3000 Hertz but mariah carey's
reaches about 3100 hertz which is pretty
impressive and in case you're wondering
frogs goldfish and turtles can only
reach a frequency of up to 3000 Hertz so
yep they can't enjoy my eyes beautiful
whistle notes like we can not an idiot
we like this one because it's just
straight to the point we all know kids
can be ruthless and sometimes they
remind us that with their test answers
this kid got asked to circle the
organism that would be classified as
plant they got presented with four
organisms but the kid gave the most
hilarious answer by saying they know the
answer is flower because they are not an
idiot absolutely amazing now get ready
because our final four kids have nothing
to do with school or test answers but
they're still just as hilarious home
theater seriously this one totally wins
this kid created the ultimate home
theater and while it's pretty funny it's
actually genius he cut out a box made a
small hole for their phone put it on top
and put the box over his head sure it
might not be practical especially if
you're claustrophobic but it's pretty
genius we have no idea how he could feel
comfortable in there but hey we get it
it's all for entertainment
wait until you see another version of
this genius that's way more
Nicolle but also way funnier reading in
a bath we bet there are a few of you out
there that are actually afraid to read
in a bath because you don't want to drop
your book or your phone well this kid
has a solution get a dog leash attach it
to the hook above the bath attach the
other end of your book and voila if you
let go of your book it'll fly up instead
of ending wet if that's not the most
hilarious thing but also the most genius
thing that you've ever seen we're not
sure what is well we might have an idea
because it's probably one of our last
two hilarious kids this kid we told you
this version of the home theater is much
better than the box version this kid
totally upgraded the box by finding a
glass table he simply placed the phone
on the glass table faced its screen down
and voila he got a home theater what a
perfect way to watch your favorite movie
of course things could get really
complicated if you were watching a
horror movie or if you wanted to switch
to another video but hey it's one of the
best thoughts that we've ever seen
be right back gonna go find a glass
table after we show you this last kids
genius cosplay we said this a lot in
this video but this is seriously the
best thing that we have ever seen this
kid totally mailed this dog cosplay and
we never even expected it we have so
many questions how what and why did that
dog actually look so good with this pink
wig
seriously this is totally brilliant and
this kid deserves all bonus points for
that awesome creation we don't even know
how they managed to make this work but
we're totally here for it well done kid
we told you these are the kids that are
so funny they're actually geniuses and
that's all for our video today let us
know in the comments section below which
kid you thought was the funniest or most
genius thanks for watching we'll see you
next time
[Music]